I think the world like lacks optimism I
think you know everyone's like your
energy your energy I've come to realize
it's just optimism
I'm just happy just positive that's what
it is just like whatever chemicals are
in my body they just allow me to see the
bright side like and I just don't think
I've realized how few people have that
like no very few people have it as black
and white hundred zero like I just think
everything's good but like you know I'm
dying knowing of eight billion people
like what the breakdown is like my gut
is like six billion just go directly
into having more pessimism and cynicism
and negativity like 5149 minimally all
the way down to very scary places and I
just don't think there's a lot of 80 80
% optimism just environment raised like
it's just all that stuff it doesn't come
naturally at a lot of people I think I
think that's like you know if if I was
able to say I'm lucky about something
forget about the business results it's
lucky that that optimism comes naturally
to me like I'm just optimistic like I
just think that so much works for me
because I refuse to accept the negative
like I you know and I don't think I hate
when people say it's you know it's an
option or it's a choice I agree with you
Susan I don't think it comes natural to
everybody I think we are just starting
on the early stages of a really looking
at mental health the brain meditation
and I do think alike
that's like saying be beautiful doesn't
come natural to everybody some of us you
know yes I'm just kidding but like you
know like you know I I do think that
some of some things are are matched with
us early on and I'm I'm so grateful I
sit here in front of the 2,000 of you
which is in itself is ridiculous like I
can turn something on in three minutes
and have 2,000 people care enough to
hear what I have to say I say with here
with ego and humility gratitude and
focus appreciation and sense of
responsibility all built around really
this optimistic foundation
that is the fuel that drives me to my
hustle and to my execution in the
marketplace
you